[Music]
so my name is Chuck Rhodes I am a senior
manager of digital infrastructure for
Pizza Hut and today I'm gonna be talking
to you about micro services born raised
and growing on Google cloud and so for
us this is really a customer journey so
we started working on building out our
service infrastructure on Google cloud
last last summer so about a year ago and
we've been able to do a lot in that time
and move forward so as it's a journey
we'll kind of talk through it in those
phases so to start with we had a plan we
wanted to build a micro service mesh
using containerized architecture in a
public cloud environment and so as we
started that we knew there were a few
key things we wanted to do so we wanted
to use kubernetes for orchestration and
since this is a Google conference I'll
just go right ahead and assume that
we've all agreed that kubernetes is the
best orchestration tool but we did do
our research we didn't just start there
we looked at other options we looked at
other technologies and we really found
kubernetes to be the best of breed for
serving public workloads private
workloads and all the things that we
were going to need to do in our
architecture next we were going to be
writing micro services and go again
Google conference so I'll assume we all
know goes the best program yelling good
but I'm not trying to start a fight
there so it's totally ok if you disagree
with me but we really felt like go has a
lot of synergies with container
architectures that made it a really
great fit so the ability to compile down
to single binaries that you can deploy
into a container
it makes your images really small it
makes your deployments really small and
it lets you be very efficient and how
you're deploying those containers into
your architecture finally we had settled
on deploying to Google cloud there were
a lot of reasons for that there were a
lot of things that went into it but key
among those was just simply google
kubernetes engine which a year ago is
called the container engine
but it still had a K for the name so it
works it was really the best in breed
way of deploying services into a public
cloud environment not having to manage
masters not having to pay for your
instances that your masters are running
on and really just the ability to have
all of the latest features of kubernetes
available in a very timely manner for
deploying your services so we had a
really good idea of what our core
architecture was going to look like so
before we kind of move forward that we
really needed to think about what
actually is a micro service as I've
heard this term used in a lot of
different ways and I think the meaning
stays a little bit fuzzy so as I was
preparing for this talk I really started
to kind of second-guess my own ideas
about a micro service and didn't really
want to be judged harshly so I thought
let me go use Google to find out what
the world says a micro services and I
couldn't find a really great definition
I found sort of you know kind of
paragraphs talking around what micro
services are but I did find a set kind
of general concepts that I think most of
us can agree on small independent
services generally we're deploying those
either into containers or virtual
machine architectures with CI CD
pipelines and ultimately those services
are interacting with one another through
service discovery and so those are good
principles those are sort of good basic
ways of describing a micro service
architecture but it still doesn't really
define what the actual micro service is
and I think there's room there for us to
have different opinions about it but for
us the really key thing was service
boundaries where are we drawing the
service boundaries now what we really
found to be great guideposts were sort
of two rules right they're not hard and
fast we can have some flexibility but
they sort of set the upper and lower
boundaries on how big we're going to
make an individual micro service so we
said every service should be as small as
possible while maintaining meaningful
business function right so when we're
trying to break services down I think
we've probably all at some point in our
career for the for the software
developers among us we've
made that mistake of making a service
too small and we eventually found we've
just created an API that we have to
write sequel in there something like
that so there is a lower boundary that
is meaningful business function but on
the other side we want to make sure that
every one of those services fully and
completely encapsulate the data and the
function that its responsible for it can
be easy to have some of these things
sort of creep in to our service
architectures where we allow our data to
be interacted with by some other kind of
batch process or something like that and
almost always it gets us in trouble so
we define these as sort of our guide
posts this is what we wanted to stay
between for our micro service
architecture so the last thing we really
had to think about before we could get
started was what kind of services are we
going to build rest is an obvious choice
it's absolutely ubiquitous when we
looked at the people who are most likely
going to be consuming the services we're
building this is what they would be
expecting to consume right they would be
expecting JSON web services over rest
protocols so it was a very good obvious
target also rest is well supported I
mean we all know every programming
language you probably want to use you're
going to be able to interact with the
rest service pretty readily the downside
with rest though for us was that there's
really no standard core message contract
when it comes to rest services and
fortunately recently open API has really
sort of become a de facto way of
defining those services and interacting
with them but it's still an
after-the-fact specification and we're
relying on the effort of the developer
and sort of our reliability to be
rigorous in how we define our services
to have those open API specs actually
mean anything we've probably had the
experience of interacting with an API
that said it was going to do one thing
and then it had something else and it
causes all sorts of bugs downstream when
you're trying to consume those services
so the other option we looked at was G
RPC and we found a lot to love there as
you can probably guess at this point
message contract was really important to
us it was something we were really
focused on
and so having protobufs as the
definition of a
you see be kind of the core piece of how
GRP Caesar put together I was a really
attractive thing right and so if you
haven't had experience the GRP see you
define those with a protobuf document
it's a very clear concise definition and
then you use a tool called proto C to
generate your stubs for servers and
clients documentation lots of things
through the plugins and so through that
we also see great tooling around G RPC
so it was definitely something we wanted
to target in our architecture but the
problem we had was it's just not as
common yet right it's still new enough
it's still not something that every
consumer who's going to pull in your
service is going to be ready to deal
with and so we wanted to make sure that
our services were friendly to our
consumers but we also want to be able to
make the best technical choices in our
architecture and so this sort of leads
to how we came up with sort of a very
simple overview of how we were going to
approach our service mesh we drew a big
distinction between a publicly exposed
API and internal services in the micro
service architecture so we said for all
of our services for all of our business
logic really the meaningful bits of what
we're doing we're going to keep those
has G RPC services and we're going to
put those behind cluster IP services in
kubernetes so if you're familiar with
that cluster IP services are only
available within the cluster which means
it's not exposed there's no public IP
accessibility but all of those services
can talk to one another service
discovery works all of those things and
then we're going to build a separate
kind of service in our cluster for our
rest servers that is based off of an
open API specification that is a REST
API that we can expose via a load
balancer server out to the rest of the
world the other nice benefit we get in
that arrangement is each of those
individual G RPC servers can fully
encapsulate the data they're responsible
for so we can follow our service
boundary rules meaning they have all of
sort of the administrative endpoints and
functionality in them but whenever we
create those rest servers and we define
that an open API we can only pull up the
methods that we actually want to expose
out to a broader audience so this was
our idea this is where we wanted to go
and we felt like we had a really solid
plan
so the next step on our journey we had a
project location location location so
hopefully everyone in this room shops
with Pizza Hut
all the time and you buy our products
online a lot and so as I talk through
this it'll sort of make sense and you'll
kind of recognize it in your experience
but our customers need to be able to
find stores online whenever they want to
place in order with us and at this point
in time when this project came to my
team we were at a place where Pizza Hut
was in a transition we were moving away
from a previous mapping provider over to
Google Maps for all of our geocoding and
customer address lookup and things like
that it provided an opportunity for us
to also retire an older service that we
were using to help with some of that
store location and delivery look up
stuff and replace that so that was our
project when we bring projects into our
team we really like to look at it from a
few specific questions we start with a
customer right what do our customers
need to be able to do and for this
service they need to be able to do two
things find all the stores in range of a
particular location and find a single
store that will deliver pizza to their
location so these are the two kind of
methods that we see evolving out of this
project and then we look at the aspects
of the service what attributes are
really important and this is where we
kind of look at usage patterns and
traffic patterns on the service so for
this one we need to return answers
really fast right we have a very high
read load because those customers are
searching for their location that's
being looked up we also need high
availability this is the first step to a
customer interacting with us online we
want to make sure that's really
available and really present and we
don't interrupt that ability to place
orders with us and finally we have a low
read load for the service we only need
to update data about once an hour our
service is not the system of record for
the things that it's using it's really
serving as an online accessibility point
and more of a cache so we took that
service architecture we started with we
said okay how do we break down this
service we need to build the first thing
was our service boundaries right so we
started looking at what our PCs are we
going to implement and we decided we
would have to we would have one that's
folk
on store information so all of the
things you need to know when you find
your store as far as where it is or
what's its phone number I'm in a
separate one that would be focused on
location type data so this would be the
thing that's doing our geo queries and
handling that information and when you
look at it you may say well it's all
really still about storage so why isn't
this one service and we had that debate
internally and actually in an early
prototype it was one service but again
we looked kind of back at our service
boundaries and how we want to define
those we said we want to make the
services as small as we can while
maintaining business function so we can
break these into so we're gonna go ahead
and do that so we had to back into RPC
services I'm supporting all the methods
so that we need to interact with our
data and then we pulled up those two
functions right finding your delivery
store and finding stores near a
particular location into our REST API
but no service works without data behind
it so we needed to solve for data
storage and I've been around for a
little while long enough to go from
talking about Greybeards to having a lot
of gray in my beard so I definitely come
from that architectural approach where
you know we would start with just one
database and we kind of throw everything
at it and kind of torque every use case
we had to fit an our DBMS system and
things like that so we didn't want to do
that here we're in the cloud now we
should be able to do things in a
different way so we wanted to pick our
data storage solution based on the
requirements we had so we said we need
high speed reads we need we have queries
that are going to be very key centric
right our location service is taking
care of kind of indexing and a lot of
the geospatial stuff and really gets us
down to a point where we're just doing
very key centric reads so we need
something that can handle that really
well and then we need multi-region scale
again high availability for our
customers we want to make sure that
whatever data solution we're using has
that same availability kind of thing to
it right so as we looked at the options
that were out there we also looked at
some of the other offerings in Google
cloud right we're only using kubernetes
engine at this point in datastore
actually solved really a lot of the main
concerns we had it will scale to
hundreds of thousands of read operations
per second so that definitely will
however this scale we need the key query
performance is amazingly fast and so
that was gonna be a really good fit and
it's just multi-region built-in right
whenever you provision out your
datastore you choose a multi region
region and you're up and running and you
have multi region support so we added
datastore to the back-end of our cluster
we're kind of starting to pick up steam
now right we have a full solution we
actually send queries to it we can do
things with it but we need to think
about how are we going to get our data
in and so this is really like I said
this is a journey we didn't know
everything going in when we looked at
kubernetes engine we were really only
looking at it from sort of very specific
lane of I'm going to have queries coming
in from the web I need to service those
and return those we weren't thinking
about other kinds of workloads so we
knew we can put our source data into a
cloud storage bucket but how are we
going to get it loaded into our
databases and that's where fortunately
as we look through kubernetes we found
there's a workload specifically for that
kubernetes has you know the concept of a
job and so we could simply create that
job we could schedule it to run and one
of the great side effects of that was
being that the job is running in cluster
we don't have to worry about extending
the methods that job needs to operate
outside of the cluster boundary so that
worked out for us really well but then
we needed to think about API management
so we have a service that ultimately we
are going to be exposing publicly and we
are going to have consumers outside of
Pizza Hut hitting so we need the proper
security and management around that we
for this particular service we're going
to use API keys as the appropriate way
of securing the API but we also want to
support for JWT tokens we knew that we
would be building services that we would
have kind of a higher need for
authorization on we also wanted usage
reports and performance statistics and
what's happening with the services we're
using them and we want to integrate with
those open API specs we made such a big
deal about having that message contract
we want to make sure whatever API
management platform we're using
integrates with that again we looked at
the service offerings in Google cloud we
compared that to other options and we
really settled on Cloud endpoints as
being a really great fit for
where we were in building and working on
our API platform so Cloud endpoints has
a really really flexible set of security
options it's it's configured
declaratively obviously sports API keys
that supports JWT tokens and it has
pluggable back in so you can use
google's off for that you can use your
own there's a rich dashboard integrated
directly into your cloud console for
your Cloud endpoints so you can very
easily look at usage by API keys you can
see the performance statistics across
your API endpoints and a lot of the
things we needed to see and finally it
is configured and deployed with open API
spec so just by tweaking a couple of
things and a couple of places on our API
specifications we were able to just
immediately deploy the cloud endpoint I
do want to zoom in a little bit on one
of the workloads we've been talking
about those so that rest service that we
have deployed when we look at the kind
of kubernetes components of that we have
a kubernetes service that's a load
balancer targeting port 443 and then we
have a REST API at kubernetes deployment
and at the time we just had a single
service in the pod write our rest server
that we built the great thing with
implementing Cloud endpoints was it was
really just a pretty minor change to
that workload you add a declaration for
the ESP container to your pod so then
the ESP is the extensible service proxy
that's actually the component that
implements Cloud endpoints and then we
just made a little port adjustment so
our rest server is on a separate port
that's only available on the pod and
then the service container can proxy to
it we're only exposing the service
through a protected Channel and we
didn't really have to change our
architecture that much right we just
added endpoints to rest containers and
we were in good shape and ready to go so
next up we needed to think about high
availability so we've kind of talked
about how we crafted the cluster and how
we put that together but we're still
really only talking about a single
cluster we needed better availability
than that so we said first of all we can
use a multi availability zone cluster
that's a feature of google kubernetes
engine where you can extend your cluster
into separate availability zones and it
will distribute your pods accordingly so
that you have available
across all of those zones at the time we
were doing this regional clusters we're
not a thing yet which are now and that's
probably what we would do and what we
actually will do going forward but even
that we're still in a single region and
you're still leaving yourself a certain
amount of exposure anytime you're
building architecture in a single cloud
region so what we really wanted was to
have multi a-z clusters in multi region
right so we have East we have west we
have across availability zones but when
we do that we need a way to get traffic
into those zones into those regions
unfortunately we don't have the ability
to do cross regional clustering quite
yet so we needed something they would
distribute that traffic and if you've
been using Google Cloud for long you'll
probably predicts kind of where we're
going with this but we needed to be able
to distribute traffic inter-cluster
we also wanted to make sure that we're
serving customers from the closest
cluster to them right so for Geographic
availability you can be served you know
for in San Fran out of a data center on
the east coast but we would rather that
not be the case if it doesn't have to be
and finally we need to remove unhealthy
clusters from the services automatically
so Google load balancer the global load
balancer solved this I mean it really
was just a direct fit for the use case
we had right it's designed for excuse me
multi region load balancing it
distributes load geographically to the
nearest back-end by default and it has
support for health checks so you can
make sure that your services come in and
go out or your backends for your
services as the health profile changes
so we put the Google cloud global load
balancer I always say the Google cloud
load balancer but we put the global load
balancer and front of our clusters and
ultimately so architecture starts to
look like this now we did have to make
one change today the global load
balancer does not really recognize the
kubernetes cluster as a thing so it
recognizes it as instance pools in of
compute right so the way around that is
to create a node port service in
kubernetes that the cloud load balancer
can address fortunately that's really
pretty straightforward to do you create
your node port service we left our load
balancer service in place because we
found it was still been
official to be able to route traffic
directly to regions or for testing and
seeing what's going on there but it got
us to this point where we had sort of
fully rationalized and fleshed out
architecture so we implemented it and we
turned it on and it worked really well
it actually served traffic really well
this was in place last year through your
Super Bowl which is our Super Bowl and a
lot of businesses talk about like what
day of the year's their Super Bowl for
Pizza Hut it is actually the Super Bowl
so this did a really great job it
performed really well the architecture
scaled as we hoped and expected it would
but along the way what did we learn and
the answer would be a lot right we
learned a lot of things and I think most
of what I've been talking about up to
this point really was us learning as we
went right learning that we needed API
management what was I going to look like
learning about needing load balancing
what is that going to look like but I
really want to highlight a few specific
things I'm sort of from you know we were
right we learned - we were wrong and so
we'll start with we were right because
it's always great to start on a high
note
gr pcs with well-defined service
boundaries worked really really well so
as of right now we are going through a
lot of upgrades and some feature changes
to some of those early services we built
and what we've really been happy to find
is that by having those service
boundaries and having them written in
our PCs we can really trust those
protobufs to be the thing we need to
target so you know the experience a lot
of us as software developers have had of
just implement the interface and your
implementation will be fine mostly we do
get the ability to carry that into our
service architecture so we can say
implement the protobuf and then do all
your performance and load testing
everything you need but you can trust
that your consumers are going to be ok
because you implemented the protobuf so
that worked really really well what we
were kind of pleased I don't know
surprised is the right word maybe
delighted but stackdriver actually
turned out to be a really amazing tool
so for us we knew in a distributed
architecture we're going to need to be
able to know what's going on with our
services and how's everything performing
right so
having stackdriver logging and tracing
available was really a huge benefit to
us from the very beginning we were
structuring our logs so that when they
did hit whatever downstream log system
they would go to they would be
searchable and accessible the
integration between kubernetes engines a
stack driver though just sort of made
all that work right we just write the
log out like we always would with
whatever components we want and I show
up in stackdriver fully broken down so
that we can search we can create metrics
and do all those things and then tracing
we we did see that we needed to do
distribute a trace from the beginning so
we said we'll implement this we'll put
it in all our services and we'll wrap
all of our call-outs in a trace boundary
and we'll be able to kind of see how the
service is performing right and so it
was it was kind of cool to look at the
charts and pull it in at the beginning
and so it was kind of fun but then we
noticed on one of the services in
particular that about a third of the
traffic was significantly more latent
than the rest of the traffic in the
service in in so much so that it was
really noticeable right when we looked
at the performance graph you sort of had
these two peaks there was one big glut
of all the traffic and in like a hundred
millisecond delay in a second peak and
so that was problematic why is a third
of our traffic so much slower than the
other traffic and the good news was it
was really easy to find out right we
just simply went in and we clicked on a
few of the traces and fortunately we had
wrapped the problem area and a boundary
and so we saw there was a call-out right
there was a place in that service for
under certain conditions we would call
to geocode a particular piece of
information and it was something that
was cashable it wasn't really a customer
specific but it's one of those
situations where because it was sort of
downstream of so many other things it
had just kind of gotten wrapped in a
library and wrapped in a library and we
didn't really count the cost of the call
anymore but through tracing we were able
to identify it we switched that over so
that we did properly cache that response
and you know we've got rid of that
second peak and moved all of our traffic
back together so from there we loved
tracing even more and then then we
noticed actually it's better than we
thought right
because tracing is great across our
services but it also integrates to cloud
endpoints and it integrates to datastore
so now I have a very rich amount of
detail all the way from the point where
traffic enters into my endpoint what
cloud endpoints does with it what
latency that introduces all the way
through my architecture and then what's
happening in the database which is a
really wonderful amount of visibility
into what's going on
with our services and finally we also
learned that our rest layer that we
talked about it does work it lets us do
the things we wanted to do as far as
pulling services up out of the our pcs
for exposing those to public but it gets
a bit boilerplate ish most of the time
as we're implementing that we're sort of
just recreating a call an open API that
we already created and protobuf and
passing it through and developers love
writing boilerplate so we left it in
place for a while but then they told me
I was wrong they don't love writing
boilerplate so we started looking at
other solutions and that kind of takes
us into where are we going from here
right so where are we going
we have several different areas that
we're looking into now so one of those
is sto and if you're looking for me
during the conference go to any of the
sto talks you'll probably find me there
because I'm attending as many as I can
we really think sto is going to be an
amazing expansion to what we do in
container architectures so if you've
worked in kubernetes you know it does do
a really great job of managing services
but there are still some things you're
doing yourself or some things that are
left to the developer to implement right
so SEO solves a lot of those challenges
so one of the things just with proxying
traffic throughout your cluster if you
implement an architecture like we have
you'll see ERP sees an HTTP to service
and so some of you may have been
thinking I was going like how did you
solve that problem of proxying G RPC
traffic inside of kubernetes and with a
lot of work that's how we solved it sto
has that built in right it is HTTP to
aware whenever it's distributing traffic
inside of the cluster and so that's a
really huge benefit the other thing is
once you have an architecture sort of
scaled out the way ours is you start to
have routing hit a lot of different
places right you have some DNS stuff
going on you have some routing and your
global load balancer each of your
kubernetes load balancers are
implementing their own load balancer and
so you have routing in that and you
ultimately kind of have how your
services are routing to and through the
clusters is a little bit kind of spread
around with this do you can declare all
of that routing in cluster and have it
really take care of managing everything
once it makes it into the mesh ingress
and finally a mutual TLS for service to
service authentication so we've really
been looking a lot at how we're doing
defense and death and where we want to
go with that
I mean sto just meshes in really well
with what we want to achieve their next
so we talked about that problem of
having those sort of rest api's and the
main use case we had for that was we
need to be able to kind of cherry-pick
specific methods out of our pcs mix
those together and sometimes transform
the requests and responses away from
what we would do in the RPC to something
that's more specific to a particular
consumer and so really what I've
described there is a lot of what Apogee
actually does so as we've matured our
services and we've looked at moving into
a little bit more of a full-featured API
management suite we're cut we're moving
in that direction and so again as I was
talking about G RPC and rest some of you
guys probably thought about why didn't
you look at the G RPC gateway because
that's pretty much what it does right it
takes your protobuf it compiles out a
rest proxy for that and so that's
actually the direction we're going to be
going now so we'll be wrapping
everything in G RPC gateway proxies that
will expose those as API is up into our
Apogee layer and then from there we will
be able to pick which endpoints we want
we'll combine those into products within
a AG and do the transformations and all
of the things we need to do there and
then where else are we going more and
more and more and more services so I
really kind of talk through a use case
with two services we've grown well past
that we've had several other projects
where we've introduced many additional
services we look a little bit more like
that initial map right where not
everything is just a service exposed
through arrests we have things that are
purely internal the cluster we have
things that are wrapping
out to the broader world we've actually
brought in other cloud products so I
didn't have a chance in this particular
use case to talk about cloud pub/sub but
that's become a really significant part
of our architecture as well and we found
anywhere that we needed to do an
asynchronous payload it's fit extremely
well into what we're putting together
and how we're approaching things
[Music]
you